okay three common issues that the
president talks about trade North Korea
and China those three issues are being
combined into one Donald Trump's new
idea is to stop all trade with any
country that does business with North
Korea okay Donald Trump took to Twitter
he tweeted the United States is
considering in addition to other options
stopping all trade with any country
doing business with North Korea of
course one of the countries that does
business with North Korea is China now I
want to be clear I'm not some defender
of Chinese government depression or the
lack of free speech or anything else
that exists there right I'm not
defending any of it but I still want to
point out why this is an absolutely an
utterly crazy idea and I want to remind
you before we even do that Donald Trump
does a lot of business with China much
of his men's clothing line is
manufactured in China a few months ago
China provisionally granted Donald
Trump's businesses 38 different
trademarks Trump is doing huge business
in China but apparently China would be
punished for doing business with North
Korea okay how many of us read about
Donald Trump's threat to North Korea on
a computer or mobile device that was
assembled partially or wholly in China
China runs many aspects of our lives
period I'm not defending it I'm not
saying it's good you can move
manufacturing elsewhere it'll take a
long time and it might cost more but if
you end trade with China because they do
business with North Korea you destroy
the American economy in a number of ways
including that immediately tons of goods
sold in the u.s. become way more
expensive that is really bad for the
lower and middle class you [ __ ] huge
American companies now some people will
like that but you'll do it in a way that
will exert downward economic pressure
and it would be hugely damaging to the
people that supposedly Donald Trump was
running for the little guy the average
person of course we never bought it but
that's who it would hurt do you think
for a second Pat that Donald Trump
understands the potential impact
of no longer trading with China trade
has been one of those issues where
Donald Trump can speak passionately
because I think you know relative to the
other issues that he knows about he's
able to be a little bit more knowledge
on it I agree and he's also not really
thinking ahead in terms of wet weather
like what would you really be punishing
China who who exactly would be punished
American buyers of Chinese goods would
still be able to buy them indirectly at
a small price increase maybe you buy
them from someone that does business
with China but doesn't do business with
North Korea and of course the
alternative would be that China can stop
trading with North Korea but trade
indirectly with them through another
country and that's sort of how the slave
trade actually worked law a law would be
passed against importing slaves from a
particular country so then that source
country would send the slaves to a
different country and then you import
them from there you're just putting in a
middleman and adding to the cost of all
of these transactions which it's insane
to think of buying humans as an economic
transaction but that is what it once was
in Trump scenario you're setting up
exactly that same situation and this is
also more broadly nonsense
because it's just not a credible threat
from Trump it's such an obviously empty
threat that it doesn't communicate
strength China knows it isn't credible
North Korea knows this is not a credible
threat so it doesn't even benefit the
United States for Trump to make the
threat there's also this five-year-old
trade deal with South Korea's a free
trade deal that he's threatening now
because he's accusing the South Koreans
of practicing appeasement when it comes
to North Korea keep in mind these are
the people that are most vulnerable to
any sort of missile attack Ernie and
supposedly our allies as well right so
it doesn't make any sense and oh by the
way North Korea also imports from Mexico
a huge huge huge trading partner for the
United States also would be disastrous
to cut that off so everybody wants this
resolved some people want it resolved in
a tweet and it's not going to be ending
trade with China and Mexico is so absurd
that it is not even remotely credible as
something that Donald Trump would do and
the likely reality is there's not going
to be a simple solution in North Korea
that doesn't involve some combination of
significant
economic conflict and/or military
involvement not that I'm recommending it
but the the idea that things are going
to drastically change in North Korea
without some combination of those two
things doesn't seem particularly likely
to me and I've been reading more and
more individuals who are saying hey you
know what we should take a different
approach to North Korea we should say
hey North Korea you know what you're a
country like other countries you can
research nuclear technology but you've
got to play by the rules you have to
allow inspectors in we will remove a lot
of the threats that you are on the
receiving end of and allow you to do the
research but you've got to play by the
rules and it's a controversial idea but
it's when I'm reading more and more
about and maybe we'll talk about it a
little bit later in the week I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the program is on
twitter at david pakman show we'll take
a break and be back after this
today's episode is made possible in part
by movement watches which is of course
it has an interesting sort of shared
history with the David Pakman show 2
Broke college kids that wanted stylish
watches started movement watches because
they couldn't afford the watches that
they would see at department stores that
cost four or five hundred dollars and
they decided to sell their products
entirely online cutting out the
middleman and cutting out the retail
markup in order to provide really
stylish looking watches starting at just
$95 I've got my movement watch on today
I know I've said this before but it
continues to happen I go places and I
see people instead of looking at my face
when I'm talking to them are actually
looking at my watch and very often say
hey what kind of a watch is that I
really like that and incredibly they are
really really affordable watch is a
fraction of what department store brands
typically charge you can go to em VMT
comm slash Pakman and get 15% off a
movement watch today you will also get
free shipping you will also get free
returns ok once again that's MVM t.com
slash PA que ma n